y en directo América actualizamos la
información económica para ello le doy
la bienvenida a mi compañero Juan Pablo
lucumí Juan Pablo empezamos con
Argentina porque allí el valor del dólar
que se vende en el mercado informal
llegó a un nuevo récord Así es Andrés
Buenos días Pues en Argentina el dólar
que se vende de manera informal como
usted lo dice se le conoce como el dólar
blue y este lleva varios días rompiendo
un techo sin precedentes y ahora se
acerca a los 500 pesos la escasez de
Divisas ocasionada en parte por las
bajas exportaciones del país pone en
riesgo el pago de las obligaciones de
este país sudamericano al fondo
monetario internacional mientras el
gobierno Busca negociar con el organismo
para poder intervenir más a fondo en el
mercado paralelo para el presidente
izquierdista Alberto Fernández la crisis
de este escenario de Divisas es culpa de
la especulación de los políticos de
derecha del país escuchemos es una
práctica permanente de la derecha
Argentina
primero
instalan rumores a la mañana
operan durante todo el día y cuando
termina la tarde retiran su rentabilidad
del mercado cambiario
y lastiman de ese modo El aro el ahorro
de la mayoría de los argentinos y
argentinas Siempre han hecho lo mismo
Juan Pablo ayer hablábamos de la pérdida
en depósitos del First Republic Bank
algo que seguro afectó a las acciones
del banco cuéntenos Andrés recordemos
que antes del internet las personas en
la Pues en la bolsa especulaban acerca
de una situación eso afectaba las
acciones hoy el internet y las noticias
es lo que Pues cambia todos los mercados
y no era para menos porque el anuncio de
ayer de las pérdidas de depósitos del
banco fueron históricas el esfuerzo en
San Francisco dijo que en el primer
trimestre los depósitos los depositantes
retiraron más de 100 mil millones de
dólares esto generó temores en nuevos
colapsos bancarios tras las quiebras del
silicon Valle Bank y el signature Bank y
supone la mayor crisis de confianza
desde El colapso Financiero de 2008
ahora vamos a ver entonces cuál fue la
jornada del día de ayer y entonces a las
8 de la mañana las acciones estaban por
allá arriba donde usted las ve en 11,5
dólares y nada más para el final de la
jornada tuvo pérdida de casi el 50%
exactamente del
49,38% hasta los 8,10 dólares Todo esto
ocurrió en el mismo día y pues ya
veremos cómo sea la apertura de hoy cómo
planea Entonces recuperarse el banco de
esta crisis pues una de sus estrategias
será la venta de activos no rentables y
el despido de hasta una cuarta parte de
su plantilla de unos 7.200 empleados
Juan Pablo y seguramente este escenario
negativo también afectó a los mercados
mundiales muéstranos pero menos mal no
afectó tanto a Wall Street porque abrió
con positivo Aunque Ninguno de los tres
indicadores con ganancias que llegan al
1% América Latina se cerró mixto con
Argentina con tercera jornada
consecutiva con ganancias aunque esta
fue menor de las anteriores con solo el
1,21%. México Perú y Colombia cerraron
el martes con pérdidas bien y Juan Pablo
los informes de resultado de las
tecnológicas tienen optimistas a sus
directores Por qué empezamos entonces
Andrés con la agenda de las tecnológicas
que presenta sus informes y ayer se los
de Microsoft y alphabet Microsoft
reportó ingresos de 52,9 millones de
dólares entre enero y marzo lo que
supone un 7% más que el mismo periodo
del año anterior ya usted conoce Andrés
la diferencia entre los ingresos y las
ganancias porque estas últimas son las
que pues la utilidad lo que le queda a
la compañía entonces las ganancias
aumentaron un 9% en el primer trimestre
de este año hasta acumular los
18.300 millones de dólares superando las
expectativas un panorama impulsado por
las ventas de computación en la nube que
ahora tiene optimistas a los directores
para planear Pues todos estos proyectos
de Inteligencia artificial Mientras
tanto los ingresos de alphabet
aumentaron un 3% hasta los
69.790 millones de dólares desde los 68
mil millones alcanzados el año anterior
pero aunque creció frente al periodo en
comparación el año pasado su porcentaje
de crecimiento fue el 23% y este año
sólo del 3% y bueno finalizamos con
nuestra cifra del día son los Bueno
antes es una pregunta usted cuenta con
la Gigante de transmisión de audio de
Spotify antes y ya no ya no Bueno
entonces usted no hace parte de los 515
millones de usuarios mensuales activos
que reportó esta Marca a finales de
marzo superando las expectativas porque
su pérdida operativa en realidad se ha
profundizado esta cifra de usuarios
activos mensuales es distinta a los 207
millones de usuarios que tiene por
suscripción de pago de la cuenta es
decir es diferente a la gente que en
realidad paga Pero usted no hace parte
de estos números No yo no hago parte de
esos números Como le decía anteriormente
es cuestión de practicidad prefiero la
aplicación que viene ya con el
dispositivo móvil que que manejo y no me
embolató tanto con Ah bueno son de
preferencias exactamente Juan Pablo
Muchas gracias por la información
económica mañana una nueva jornada
entonces con Ángela Gómez Ya no estaré
yo acompañándolo en esta jornada pero
mañana con mucho más de economía
Igualmente exactamente más noticias de
economía mañana